wait don't eat that why not it's run oh
I guess you're right I bought it today
but I didn't really check every single
Apple in the bag it's such a lot of work
to make sure all apples are good it can
be unless she can get some help from
machine learning with automail vision
you can train a visual recognition model
quickly and easily using your own
pictures so you think better automate
this kind of thing look see it's a
hundred percent run Wow this makes
quality control looks so easy can you
show me how it's done
sure thing
built this web app using a model trained
on pictures of free since we've trained
it on a data set of good and bad apples
when I take a picture of a new Apple
it's able to accurately figure out if
it's good or bad like I did for your
Apple the model clearly recognized it as
bad that is really cool
how would I build one myself let me show
you how it's done it all starts in the
Google Cloud console first things first
we need a data to train the model on
here we've got a Google Cloud storage
bucket full of images the images are
divided into rotten and fresh folders
I've created a CSV that lists all of the
images and the labels I've used a quick
script to do that as there are thousands
of images but you can use the auto ml
interface to do this manually
let's take a look at the interface now
here we need to create a dataset it's
really easy go to new data set give it a
name choose how you want to import your
images in our case I'm just going to
point it at the CSV and then hit create
they'll import them from GCS this may
take a few minutes now that we have all
the images imported and labeled we can
train the model on them all to our mouse
takes care of splitting the data set for
training validation and testing so you
don't have to worry about that just hit
start training and let Google cloud
handle the rest this can take anywhere
from 15 minutes to several hours
depending on the size of the dataset so
let's switch to a model that's already
trained once you have trained your model
you can test the prediction right here
in the interface just upload a picture
and look at the result there is an API
endpoint too and that's what I linked my
app to simple no service to manage no
code to train that is fantastic now I
can easily train my own visual models
for apples food or just about anything
else
exactly if you like this demo don't
forget to subscribe for more great
Google cloud platform content
[Music]